AFFIDAVIT TO THAT VERY FACT.
HERE WITH MORE IS PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY.
HE'S DONE WORK FOR ME ALSO IN
THE PAST.
BUT THEY GOT A BIGGER CLIENT
NOW.
GOOD FOR HIM.
ALSO, THE -- THE CHIEF COUNSEL,
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE, JAY SECULA.
>> THANK, SEAN.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT,
THEY, THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY
AND THE MEDIA HAVE DECLARED WAR
ON THIS PRESIDENT.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT'S
REALLY AGAINST THE SMELLY
WALMART PEOPLE LIKE ME ANDER
REDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES AND
PEOPLE WHO CLING TO GOD, GUNS,
BIBLES, AND RELIGION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE WHO WE ELECTED
AND THEY WANT TO UNDO AN
ELECTION IN ALL OF THIS.
>> WELL, LOOK, I MEAN, HERE'S
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE RUSSIA HOAX ENDED UP BEING
NOTHING WHEN BOB MUELLER
ATTEMPTED THAT TESTIMONY,
WHATEVER THAT WAS, THAT GOT HIM
ZERO.
THE REPORT WAS NOTHING.
THE TESTIMONY WAS NOTHING.
THEN THEY COME OUT WITH THE
UKRAINE.
NOW, I WANT TO READ SOMETHING IN
THIS SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER, I
CALL SPY.
I DON'T KNOW THE PERSON
OBVIOUSLY, BY THE WAY.
BUT WHEN YOU READ WHAT THE
INDIVIDUAL WROTE, IT SOUNDS LIKE
SPYING.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT IS
WRITTEN, I WAS NOT A DIRECT
WITNESS TO MOST OF THE EVENTS
DESCRIBED.
THIS IS HEARSAY IN OUR VIEW.
BY THE WAY, IF THE WITNESS
ACTUALLY SAID THAT IN A COURT OF
LAW IN THE MIDDLE DISTRICT OF
GEORGIA, SAY, IN MAICON, THEY
WOULDN'T BE ADMITTED TO COURT.
IT'S CALLED HEARSAY.
NOW, HERE'S AN INTERESTING FACT.
IT'S JUST COMING TO LIGHT RIGHT
NOW.
THIS -- THIS PERSON SAYS THEY
HAVE NO FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS.
THEY HEARD THIS FROM OTHER
PEOPLE.
THE FORM THAT SO-CALLED
WHISTLEBLOWERS FILL OUT USED TO
SAY THIS -- IN ORDER TO FIND AN
URGENT CONCERN CREDIBLE, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL MUST BE IN
POSSESSION OF RELIABLE FIRSTHAND
INFORMATION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND THE INDIVIDUAL
MAKING THE COMPLAINT.
SO THAT WOULD BE THE FIRSTHAND
INFORMATION HAS TO HAVE
FIRSTHAND INFORMATION.
THAT WAS ON THE FORM LITERALLY
UNTIL APPARENTLY VERY RECENTLY.
NOW I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT DATE
OF THE CHANGE, BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
IT COULD HAVE BEEN CHANGED AS
LATE AS JULY OR AUGUST.
I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT DATE YET.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU, MONTHS AGO,
NO FIRSTHAND INFORMATION, NO
REPORT.
SO WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS HEARSAY.
SECONDLY, WHAT ABOUT THE
HEARSAY?
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS
WE'VE GOT INDIVIDUALS INSIDE OF
SOME AGENCY THAT ARE LISTENING
TO THE PRESIDENT'S
CONVERSATIONS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THEM.
SO THEY WANT THEM OUT.
SO, THE WHITE HOUSE BEING FULLY
TRANSPARENT RELEASED THESE
TRANSCRIPTS.
NOW, LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
THE TRANSPARENCY IS GREAT, BUT
IF YOU THINK THIS IS GOOD FOR
AMERICA THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THIS?
GUESS AGAIN.
FOREIGN LEADERS WILL BE
HESITANT.
IT'S MY CONCERN -- IT'S ALWAYS
MY CONCERN.
FOREIGN LEADERS WILL BE HESITANT
IN ENGAGING IN PHONE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THIS KIND OF
NONSENSE GOING ON.
LET ME TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER.
NANCY PELOSI ANNOUNCES THAT
SHEP'S GOING TO START THIS
FORMAL IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, SUBSTANTIVELY
NO DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THEY'VE
BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST YEAR OR
THREE.
THEY DO NOT REFER THIS TO THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
>> Sean: WHY NOT?
>> FOR ARTICLES -- TO BE
REFERRED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
SHE DID THAT BEFORE SHE EVEN
READ THIS REPORT.
SO WHAT DO YOU HAVE HERE?
THIS IS NOT A LEGAL MATTER.
I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THIS.
I KNOW MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE,
RUDY GIULIANI IS GOING TO BE ON.
THIS IS NOT A LEGAL MATTER.
THIS IS PURE POLITICS.
AND WHATEVER THE POLITICAL
CALCULATION IS, WHICH I THINK IS
A VERY DESPERATE MOVE, IF THEY
WERE TO MARCH DOWN THIS PATH, I
THINK IT'S POLITICAL SUICIDE FOR
THOSE THAT WOULD DO THAT.
BECAUSE WHAT A SIGN OF
DESPERATION.
DOES ANYBODY REALLY BELIEVE THAT
14 SECONDS UTTERS IN THAT
STATEMENT, IN THE CONVERSATION,
IF YOU PUT ALL OF THE REFERENCES
TO JOE BIDEN AND THE HUNTER
BIDEN, WHICH IS TWO.
AND THE ENTIRE SITUATION
TOGETHER AND YOU PUT IN MY
COLLEAGUE'S REFERENCE TO RUDY
GIULIANI RAISED BY THE WAY BY
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, HE
FIRST RAISED IT.
I THINK IT MAY EQUAL 20 SECONDS,
30 SECONDS.
AND A CONVERSATION THAT WAS A --
>> Sean: 33 MINUTES.
>> I'M SURE -- THE TRANSLATION
IS A THIRD OR LESS THAN THAT.
BUT IT'S PROBABLY, AT LEAST YOU
KNOW, 15, 20 MINUTES.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT?
GO AHEAD, START THE PROCESS.
VOTE.
BECAUSE THIS IS BORDERING -- NOT
ONLY ON THE ABSURD, BUT I THINK
THERE IS A DERELICTION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES IF YOU
IGNORE THE CONSTITUTION ITSELF.
THERE'S NO HIGH CRIME.
NO MISDEMEANOR.
NO VIOLATION OF THE LAW, RULE,
OR REGULATION.
IT'S ALREADY BEEN -- THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHEN THEY LOOKED AT
IT, SAID THERE WAS NO VIOLATION